[Music]
Runk Sacramento where you at Sac
Sacramento where you at I'll be there
January 13th and then in Brea I'll be in
Brea California January 18th to 19th and
then Phoenix Arizona January 20th El
Paso Texas Albuquerque New Mexico the
26th and 27th uh kala BC and Vancouver
BC February 9th and February 10th and
then I added a show in Vancouver because
it's sold out February 10th Rochester
New York kitner Ontario shareport
Louisiana Houston Texas Corpus chrisy
Texas got a bunch of uh dates coming up
come to chris.com to get the tickets and
also go to watch grow or die my new
special uh out there on my website
chris.com go ahead and get that and uh
that's that you can also get the merch I
was wearing it today uh and uh looked
pretty good might I say man uh chris.com
and without the further Ado whatever you
know how they say uh we are going to get
into the next episode of
[Music]
congratulations
congratulations man I'll tell you what
uh
well I guess we could talk about you
know what dude maybe we should just get
into it I how about this I don't I'm
going to go ahead I took my magic mind
okay on and popping clear
mind so I guess I'm ready
dude uh I'm gonna get into
it I don't understand all the stuff
online about Joe Koy I don't get why
everyone is roasting the crap out of him
I don't get it I think this is just a
frenzy that people are doing this
because of one cutway to Taylor Swift
and then another cutaway to maybe
someone else that wasn't laughing and
they just thought you know what this it
caught Wildfire dude I watched it and
not only did he not Doo bad he did
well I don't I don't understand m i mean
maybe the Barbie joke fell a little bit
flat but this is always what happens at
the Golden Globes this is always what
happens at the Golden Globes I mean
Ricky D probably gave the best monologue
ever in in in Golden globe's history and
I I don't know if people are comparing
him to that but there's all this these
gigs are terrible these gigs are
terrible to do they're actors and
actresses they're famous celebrities
that that don't want to get roasted and
this is what it's
become you know they think they want to
get roasted and then and then and then
they're like but like they don't dude
you think Margo Robbie wants to get
roasted for what for what you think
Taylor like Taylor Swift joke this the
biggest thing the most annoying thing
was the Taylor Swift thing dude the joke
wasn't about her the joke was about what
cucks the NFL areb in for showing the
relationship she should be happy about
what he did because she's like yeah
you're right the NFL is too it's too
much but she she she they they cut to
Taylor
Swift and she was like I guess not
laughing which by the way you know you
never know what's on these people's mind
she it wasn't like she was like
this she would just drank a Dr she might
have been already on the way to drink it
while Joe Koy was saying the
thing and then and then the camera
caught her Wally did the thing and then
that's it and then everyone's like oh
wow she straight-faced him you don't
even know what's going on in her head
number one number two say she was pissed
off about the
joke it's not it's not about her it's
about the
NFL
okay and also
you think Taylor
Swift why would why would why would
anyone want to ever get roasted if
you're Taylor Smith Taylor
Smith Taylor Swift why would you want to
get roast everybody in her
Camp is on
her nut so dude nobody's ever telling
her how it really
is she worth Bell
she's worth a billion dollars she makes
$400 million in merch in one show you
know nobody's gonna be everyone's gonna
be like oh sucks what sucks what he did
in her Camp sucks what he did that was
rude
yeah celebrities they don't first of all
they don't know what they
want they think they're going to go a
fun roast show and then dude the jokes
weren't they were not
bad and neither was you know you want to
say oh yeah oh people my favorite thing
is oh he missed the point about Barbie
he missed the point he didn't get Barbie
dude he just made a joke who gives a
[__] it's so
weird it was so weird I was I I look I
rarely look online so because I don't
like looking at like hate stuff for
anyone and but I did cuz you know Joe's
a buddy and I watched the thing and I
was like I can't that people are saying
it's bad no no I watch it I thought I
feel like I watched a different
monologue I don't understand I think
it's just one of those things that
caught fire and people are like all
right yeah you know the the swifties or
whatever were like this was so stupid
this was shitty because he made a joke
at her expense
expense and then uh everyone just kind
of jumped on
board I don't understand it maybe I mean
I guess I'm the minority I I don't even
know if I am the minority cuz this is
just online like 3% of people are on are
are are are are
online or on Twitter whatever the
whatever the
[__] I I it's just we I don't know what
people expect in the go are people
expecting Rick and deres Ricky what
Ricky deres did was right time right
place he's he's so funny you know and
and and he was just being himself and by
the way I bet some of those jokes fell
flat too in the room cuz he
was
I the people who saying that jokoy
bombed I just don't understand it
because you can hear the laughter it's
so weird am I maybe I'm I'm not
delusional oh yo he didn't make [__]
Tom Hanks laugh or he didn't make what
call somebody else laugh or whatever it
is what Timothy shalam didn't
laugh Timothy sport Chet didn't
laugh
Wonka did well huh I thought Wonka was
going to was going to tank Wonka made
money
right Wonka
movie uh box
office I thought Wonka was gonna okay
Wonka is number one box office
again
again that's
crazy who gives a [__]
F about Willie Wonka's origin story you
know they're going to have [__]
there's so many origin stories now
they're gonna have Dave from uh Wendy's
origin story remember
him when he was a
boy he had a thing for
redheads and square fried
chicken and square meat bro Wendy
thought they were doing something
different with the square meat get out
of here bro that's disgusting cubed ass
meat cubed ass meat
[__] [__] you cubed ass meat
[__] F so rude um Wendy's was
like Cubed
meat
um yeah
dude I mean I don't know people are so I
guess it's a slow news day with this
[__] it's like with the jco thing and
then the and then how crazy everyone
went for the cat Williamson which I
talked about in the patreon episode I I
just don't
like people
think you know you can just become
famous by
saying Hollywood is a
macrocosm to anyone's to your work right
to your career because everyone sees
Hollywood
so everyone pretty much is pretty much
everyone is a is a in in some way a
failure right like let's just get down
to Brass tax here you're not living the
life you want okay you're just not I got
news for you there's people like Brad
Pit probably not even living the life he
wants okay and I know I know oh but well
he could take his $200 million and
[__] buy an island and just go there
with you know whatever a bunch of babes
and and [__] make you know
grow weed if that's what he wants to do
right I I know I get it but money
doesn't make you happy it makes things
comfortable for you um but people think
that you
can you know buy your way into happiness
but that
aside take the money thing out of it
most people poor okay so even if you do
add that most
people when it comes down to Brass tax
we're all failures in a way right we
didn't do the thing we wanted to do
whatever it is and that's fine and I
feel you dude there's stuff in my life I
wanted to do that I didn't get to do you
know I love my life but I get
it um
so there is then there's Hollywood you
look at Kate Blanchett you look at
Jennifer Lawrence you look at Brad Pit
you look at Tom Cruz you look at you
know Kevin Hart you look at uh whoever
these people
are they're held up on a pestal by a lot
of
people but we want to see them fall so
much
because they couldn't have got it
through hard work
or talent because then that means I have
less of
that I have less of that oh yeah Brad
Pit got that [__] because of the way the
elite
uh work their magic and he's in the
Illuminati not that I didn't work hard
enough not that the cards didn't work
out for me not that I'm the kind of
person that uh isn't talented not to say
that Brad Pen's the most talented guy on
the Earth but I you know he's a good
actor and [__] but it's like people want
an excuse so badly so when Cat Williams
comes in and says Hey Kevin Hart is a
plant hey uh Cedric Entertainer does
this Joe Rogan does that then all of
those failures think I [__] knew
it I knew it I knew it wasn't because I
didn't get off my ass five days a week
to Chase my dreams I knew it and I know
it's hard it's hard as [__] to chase
your dreams bro people talk about hey
never give up your dreams dude I'm the
first to be like hey give up your
dreams dreams are hard to actualize
that's why they're
dreams you ever fall asleep and dream
something that you could
do yeah sometimes you tell anybody about
that dream no why because it's not
interesting you tell people about the
crazy
dreams because that's what's
interesting I had a dream to become a
stand-up comedian that [__] was hard as
[__] I went I did shows at La mats I did
shows in [__] where W houses and
comic book stores people's houses and
hosts I did [__] trash gigs it was
hard am I living my dream you don't know
you don't
know you don't know what makes you
happy so when you look at a thing like
Cat Williams mouthing off on all these
[__] you could be like yeah
dude that's why that's why I didn't make
it as an opera singer
when in
actuality you weren't working on your
oh as much as you should have you
weren't working on
your as much as you should have because
you were too busy eating funions playing
[__] Dark Knight or whatever video
game it makes too much it's there will
always be that feeling too I don't know
it's people love watching people
[__] I don't know this is just me
saying [__] what the [__] do I I I what
what do I know dude I'm just a guy who
posted a [__] thing on threads that
said something about uh sunglasses hey I
saw a guy wear look at this look at this
[__] I posted on threads that that that
[__] Instagram
thing the Facebook uh one third day in a
row someone with sunglasses at the gym
somebody write
so
um here
look uh let me just go down and look
at Okay and like imagine writing just
being
someone in [__] St Petersburg Florida
you know and a comedian that you don't
even like right like this person
doesn't def you don't hate me they're
just like this is a who cares response
to just write to me a
comedian Okay and like they just [__]
crazy look at this look at this third
day in a row you haven't minded your own
business huh this is
threats what do you also the thing that
the person always gets mad at online is
always you can always direct it back on
themselves right like who asked you oh I
didn't ask
you oh you just sit on the internet and
[__] about people well what's you
doing wait there was one in here I
caught there's a bunch of them here
um look at this look oh wow this is
great this one's great there's actually
one guy in the Jim who wears them every
single time I'm beginning to think he
may have an eye condition though it just
seems improbable that he'd always wear
them but he's but it is weird seeing
someone bench with shades on you
know look at this look at this some
people may have some people have
sensitive eyes I wear sunglasses most of
the time otherwise I'm my eyes
sting oh yeah
dude is that right is that right
is that right someone in Bend
Oregon hey dude okay hey did you get
your prescription of boring pills
filled
dude look
it wait there was another good one
though most of these responses are fine
the lighting can be unpleasant don't
judge okay
oh oh yeah I should just write by to oh
yeah there was one maybe it was deleted
but oh Wild
guy I don't
know I I don't
know oh here we go oh here we go here
here this is my favorite
yeah but some people with low visibility
and light sensitivity like myself don't
need your rubbish opinion about how it
about about it thanks you should
probably well first of all they say you
should probably remind your own
business remind it hey dude remind your
own
business also so British to call someone
rubbish you know that's absolute rubbish
your your your opinion your opinion is
absolutely manal it's rubbish me what is
going on I said makes no sense let
people mind their own business let
people wear sunglasses at night oh knows
what if he's a little boy what if he's
the little boy in in anatomy of the fall
and you just didn't realize it was
him what what if it was the little boy
the little blind boy with the glass out
eyes with the cloudy vision [__] in a
in in in the movie that was the French
movie anatomy of a
Faller did you see that movie anatomy of
a fall
bro I put it on solely for the reason it
was number eight on iTunes movies and I
go when I see a movie that's number
eight on iTunes
movies and on the top of the charts and
I and I don't and I don't know and I
don't either know what it is or it's got
dragons on it and [__] like cuz I don't
know a lot of movies where like that'll
just be about a wizard and sometimes I
know that there are big big movies about
Wizards and dragons that I have no idea
that they are and I understand that
those are probably Blockbusters okay all
right or if it's just a movie with like
Mel Gibson that I've never heard of that
came out in the past five six years I
get it because Mel Gibson people are
watching him number one because they
love Mel Gibson and number two because
they want to watch a movie to hate on
because they think he's an anti-semite
right okay so
okay but when I see a movie that I have
no idea what it is and it's called
called something boring as [__] like
anatomy of a fall and it's number eight
and I'm and I'm on the I'm on the couch
I'm I'm on a couch picture me not on the
couch like
this you can't cuz I'm deep in
conspiracy how the [__] did this get up
there what what what is this Danish what
is this you play it is it French but
they're speaking English too and they're
also even speaking another language what
is this you see the trailer and boy they
got me okay it said it was KH it was in
can
the won the poor detor the can whatever
the [__] it is poor poor cans selion or
whatever you see those wreaths you know
and you're like all
right Toronto Film Festival wreaths okay
I'm in you
know it was about a woman whose
husband question mark commit suicide by
jumping off of the top floor of their
house and there is a
um a hearing you know they they there's
an investigation about her they can't
prove it's not her but they they don't
know if it's her so she has to go to
like court and let me tell you something
it's French court and let me tell you
something French Court be silly as [__]
any Court that's not in
America is so
silly dude just Google YouTube like
British you know uh trial or or go or do
like
Swedish they don't they do they'll dress
up in like [__] Pirates hats and red
capes and like cotton like cotton candy
boots and they're just like here we have
you
know exhibit
a how could she have been in the
room before the dinner was
served it's impolite to be in the room
before the dinner is served therefore H
she could not have been there my client
is innocent I rest my case and then I'm
eating your cutton candy shoes like dude
it's just so crazy in America they just
go in suits and they're just like let's
get the job done bro in in Britain hey
in Britain oh dude hey if you're on
trial in Britain you sit in the
middle how do you not look
guilty in the
middle
wh I swear I didn't you know at least in
America you could be like yeah I didn't
no I didn't there's no way in Britain
dude try not looking guilty when there's
someone looking at you from here dude
you're in the middle dude there's bad
seats
well I didn't I swear I didn't kill this
is mentle this guy take your wig off
right like a [__] wig mate you got to
change this [__] it's not me dude the
only thing worse would be if the chair
rotated and you could it was like the
[__] uh The
Voice well then where were you March
15th I was was I was I was having dinner
with a business partner mate I swear let
me tell the other
side I was with a I was a business with
a dinner party I
swear dude you sit in they might as well
make you sit halfway underground to
where it's just your chest above the
floor and they're they're just like did
you I mean it's dude Court anywhere but
America is
crazy it's like all ceremonial and [__]
cuz you know why because it's been
around too long right America's been
around since 1776 if you're not counting
the
Indians but dude the you know the
Indians didn't have trials they would
just be like I don't know what they
would do but they would just like
dude it's been around too long that's
the thing the court in America in a
thousand years going to be crazy it's
going to be CRA first of all it's going
to be AI the judge will be Johnny 5 you
know
guilty but
dude yeah you can't like that's the
tradition messes everything up right you
know because times change so hey Britain
par British Parliament take your [__]
wigs
off hey you
know also we don't need that [__]
Gunk Gunk Order in the Court anymore
America get get get away with that get a
[__] uh just a button that you press
that says you know order like a game
show order laugh now at a sitcom you
know
um yeah dude I just I I it's so crazy to
me you know I don't know imagine being
in [__] god imagine not imagine not
like imagine something where you're
in on trial for something dude that's
the craziest thing is the people who are
innocent the people who go to trial and
then get cleared and are actually
innocent bro they had to go through
that how about that how about being
totally innocent you ever think about
that but you got to go through a
trial oh no and then a lot of times
they'll go through they'll win and then
they they go like this psych we got to
do it again what bro I was watching I
was watching this
um trial on Dat it was like Dateline it
was something with Kei Morrison you know
where he's just standing out in a field
for no reason near a ladder well it was
a beautiful night for Karen except for
the fact that she
died it was
[Music]
raining so full of life B
deny that's Keith Morrison so full of
life of a d night when she took her last
breath I'm Lester Holt here's the guy
that'll announce here here's I'm Lester
Holt I'm the announcer of the show that
has an
announcer this is Dateline today we'll
discuss a crazy case let me introduce
you to the guy who's going to introduce
you to the
case I'm ler I'm basically dead
space my job shouldn't exist I'm like a
segment producer on
chemel um but yeah I know
so I was watching the thing this lady
had to go on
trial four [__]
times until they convicted her hey dude
if you don't get it right the first time
I feel like it's done if you can't get
if you're a prosecution and you can't
get people you can't gather up enough
evidence for the first time hey
dude that guy deserves to
go oh well we're letting a killer on the
loose yeah well the prosecution was
[__] busy not working hard
right okay they didn't gather up enough
evid it's all uh what do you call it uh
circumstantial dude what about crafty
Killers who get away with it can you be
so good at your job that you get that
you
do like ninjas you know they don't get
caught imagine the Ninja on trial he'd
have to get like your honor he obviously
did it look what he's wearing first of
all second of all he's so good at
killing and that's why we didn't know it
was him because he's so good at it and
he was so
quiet there's no Fingerprints of course
because look at his hands he's got
gloves I rest my
case he's like I and then the
prosecution I I there is no he has no
alibi number one number two there were
hints
of just fizzing at the mouth
ninja got with one those or poison him a
day po po po po poison him with A Time
release capsule you
know uh
anyway what the [__] I I just can't
believe imagine going on trial four
times for something and then F dude and
that's what like 15 years of your life
you might the stress dude you'd probably
like I dude if you had to go on two oh
man
that's [__] crazy
dude
anyway [__] what a what a what a I
what a wacky episode I I just came out
the gates and that's good but
uh oh speaking of courtroom drama this
[__] OS Oscar Pistorius was released
Pistorius
Pistorius Olympic athlete convicted of
murder is released it's crazy if anyone
who kills anyone is ever released by the
way how long do you think you should go
to jail if you kill somebody I like what
is this 25 to Life [__] it should just
be life or we should just come up with
another amount like dude I'm sure
Killers don't want to go to jail for 10
years just make it 10 years or make it
life
don't the South African Sprinter whose
trial for the 200 2013 killing of his
girlfriend Drew intense Global interest
sered more than seven years in prison
and he and he got and he got out
oh cuz it's in South Africa right they
don't know what they're doing hey let
them out
H I don't know what what what was he in
for I don't know look it up a [__] it
it's crowded let him
out um Oscar Pistorius the South African
athlete hailed as an inspirational
figure until he was convicted of killing
his
girlfriend was released on parole on
Friday for more than after more than
seven years in
prison I watched the uh documentary on
this dude
um
yeah God I can't I I go back and forth I
have a thing that I do in my head I have
a game well it's not a game it's just
like a you know I have OCD so I I like I
have like interest of thoughts but I
have this uh thing where I think because
I don't know that I don't know the I
don't know the answer to this but ask
yourself this
would you
rather kill someone or be killed
yourself now I get the knee-jerk
reaction is kill someone because you
don't want to die okay and you have a
lot to live for I get right I get it
but deeply
imagine killing
someone and I don't mean in self-defense
I'm talking
about you have a you have a choice like
if God or Nicholas Cage comes down and
is like hey you have to make this Choice
kill someone or be
killed and they say like well who do you
know who do I kill they say that's up to
you like you can't kill it's not
self-defense it's not like you have a
threat I go back and forth on that dude
I go back and forth on that
genuinely
for a
while all throughout my youth up until I
was like 35 I'd be like I would kill I
would kill
someone and then I was
like I don't know if I could [__]
deal with that I don't know if I could
deal
with like I here's here's what I think I
think I could block
out the fact that I maybe I would
[__] it would eat me right the
hardest part about it I'll say
is I'd be walking around thinking like
when are they going to find out that is
I can't live with that when are they
going to find out when are they going to
find out I killed a [__] the bagger
at Ralphs you know I picked the oldest
guy I could I had to like I he has a f
like
I and and then
just after like I was like in my 40s I
started thinking like I think I would
just
choose to be killed because I don't want
to do that
right and I was there for a few years
and then I was like no now I now I'm at
the point where like I need to be around
for my kids like look at me look at this
this is what I this is the [__] I think
of you know how like you're at work all
day and you're like where are the
reports I got to do this oh let me send
that email out this is me I'm here in
this head space outside outside of a
[__]
aroan just like no you know what I'd
kill someone
Jesus
Christ got to up my up my uh
proac intrusive thoughts for the win huh
um but yeah anyway I guess he killed her
he was convicted of killing his
girlfriend
um oh yeah he's a double ampute that's
right CU he was a runner oh no no no the
par Olympic Athlete yeah wow man I need
kill someone with no legs they should
they got to let him out just for that
reason you know they're like well look
we had to put you in jail but it's
pretty [__] impressive man
um it's pretty impressive you'll do
seven years you won't serve a full term
you're not even a full
person
um what's
this well oh
wow oh my
God I mean Lil nzx you
know the
[__]
HSPA
oh Lil Naas X has a new single
called J
Christ hey
dude
just call it Jesus Christ you know we
all know that's not a wink we
know you might as well just call it jesa
Christ like it's pretty much we'll get
it you know it's called J Christ and
it's out
Friday and the cover of it
is oh my lil Naas x on a cross being
crucified and being taken down from from
the
cross s sacriligious dude hey where is
tits don't I thought L nozz Got Boobs
didn't he didn't he put [__] fake
boobs on for
something uh I don't know I'm just I'm
just Prejudice I guess I don't know
dude going to the very depths of hell
you
know yo how crazy is this I was thinking
about this the other day and then it
happened Tiger Woods I was like I want
is he still sponsored by Nike and after
years they part they they they split I
was just thinking about this as like who
if you were to name the best golfer in
the world everyone would say Tiger Woods
but that's going to change one day right
and you know I know he like had a dip
when he cheated all over his wife and
his wife hit him with the golf club or
whatever the [__] it was and it's
like look he shouldn't be doing
that he shouldn't be doing that
right but like how many what percentage
of guys are
like but look if you're going to do it
if you're gonna be married to somebody
who's going to be doing it at least it
was Tiger Woods
right 27 years of of sponsorship so
Tiger Woods even was sponsored through
that through that sh crazy [__] that's
wild just Tiger Woods just do it but not
that not well
Tiger Woods it's it's like this Tiger
Woods just do
it
um
Man start to finish without singing it
yeah okay whenever you're ready recite
the alphabet from start to finish
without singing it yeah okay look you
can already tell this is going to be a
[__] travesty and a train wreck
because because of the way the cop is
being she's got this woman is pulled
over for a you know drunk driving I bet
I guess right using my deductive
reasoning here I'm not sure luck
but the [__] Shure attitude he has in
the voice you know he's already got her
in he's got it in the bag right you know
he's like's he's got it in the [__]
bag he's like well this this lady's
going to be right she's GNA we got we
got her it was like that [__] OS
ladies and gentlemen we got
him whenever you're ready whenever
you're
whenever you're ready sweetie pie come
on he might as well have said sweetie
pie whenever you're ready sweetie pie
you recite the alphabet from start to
finish without singing it yeah okay when
without singing it what's that all about
ready [__] that no I don't do that I'll
sing it AB BC d e f g like this h i j k
l o p q r
s
t v double yeah X Y and
[Music]
Z god dude my son would laugh so hard at
what I just
did here we go here we go here we go
here we go come on recite the alphabet
from start to finish without singing it
yeah okay whenever you're ready
AC dude that's like a character drunk
ACB
a c
e
b d e f g h h i f n
g h i FNG G she's just spelling words
incorrectly h i c k l m n o p h q e s oh
dude saying
websites dude she threw another h on the
back end and she threw another h on the
back
end h q e s i t
e it's Coy she spelled dude the cop just
shoots her okay all right the way he
said okay all right well so you're going
to jail for 25 years could you recite
the alphabet from start to finish
without singing it bro yeah okay
whenever you're ready ACB so let's what
these are ACB b e f g h a a ACB
d e f g s
h s c was one was three letter a a c h h
i f n g f i n g f i n g thing um h i c k
hi i c k
hick l m n o p l m n o p there you go if
she got that wrong that would be that's
that's the crazy run of the alphabet if
you get LML P wrong you are brain debt
you're vegetable you're basically a
chair that's unbelievable if you get
Elemento she got that right that's not
saying much she could be like her blood
alcohol level could be five she still
get elemental P right then it's QRS
let's see what she says HQ s h
qes dude a video game
system Dark Knight available on
everything except for HQ
s HQ ES HQ s so she's she's confirming
by the way it is HQ s it it okay all
right okay all right going to jail for
90 years uh do the the fact that she
thinks that the alphabet ends with
e is unreal dude wow for real throw her
under the
jail bro how many AG well so first thing
is first
first how tell me I really forget how
many h's are actually in the alphabet
first so you can tell me
please h a b c hi j k h j k l o h jkp
qhi j
[Laughter]
k ah man did we already play this
Jumbotron thing on the the the
suck
I think we already did
it but it was so funny dude I think we
did it on the on the patreon
episode you fear the least fish animal
what's the animal in this world that you
fear the least fish
animal
fish don't don't start don't don't
you're starting and I'm not a fish is an
animal no it's not I'm talking about an
animal animal like a real animal like
fish idot fish fish fish no hard-headed
I'm talking about like that's like
saying like an ant that's not an animal
IDI hey hey dude not everyone should
have a
podcast you know these guys should even
be hanging out let alone filming it
aren't animals that's like a that's a c
creature dude that's the problem of
podcast now is is too many uh uh
combinations of people are happening to
where you're like well they shouldn't
even be hanging out
together people are just like I want to
start a
podcast you have a podcast yet I got one
yeah but you don't you you got time to
do another one right yeah let's do it
what it's a sea creature a fish is an
animal you can't go to the zoo and see a
fish they don't have they don't have Zoo
fishes there's actually so many fishes
there's fish zoos you can go to a fish
zoo no there's so many fish that they
have their own attraction called an
aquarium no they don't no that's these
guys have this what's weird is these
guys have the exact same
voice
um
okay I don't know man you can have a pet
fish so another action card for us to
find and it looks like a good one the
first thing to address is the gray pants
which tell us it's an away game and
instead of looking at the jerseys let's
identify the stadium we're in so we can
see what team the A's are playing this
guy just evaluates baseball cars
pictures of baseball car trying to link
the Evan Williams Brand to something but
obviously Kentucky doesn't have a pro
team the answer was actually right there
all along that would be the logo for
globl field home of the Texas Rangers
Kemp played in nine games that Oakland
was visiting the Rangers and the Jersey
lineup looked like this so we can
eliminate all but two games now he's
listed as a second baseman and an
outfielder so I thought this was a
flyball catch it first somewhere maybe
along the warning track but thanks to
this panoramic shot of the field we can
see the entire Outfield has a yellow
stripe to indicate the dude this guy is
just trying to find find the day the
baseball card was
taken the day the baseball card picture
was taken this guy dude there are too
many people in the
world when guy can spend any amount of
time deciding what day that I always did
wonder that though when I would see
baseball cards I be like how imagine
you're doing it you don't even know what
day that is like even if you're like you
know Hensley muin or [__] Howard
Johnson you still don't know right you
be like I don't remember that game
that's pretty [__] interesting what
what what but this is who the
[__] that's clearly not in the picture
so it looks like this this is taken
either near or in foul territory he was
super busy in the July 23rd game but
only had one popup to take care of this
guy looked at the [__] what happened
so guy's going to catch a a base a
baseball he's going to see what games
out of two that he caught a baseball
like that a lead man on
base and Garcia goes after the first
pitch and that popup will be handled by
Kemp that one's just not even close so
let's look at
the July 9th match up where we get two
defensive outs but only one pop fly in
foul
territory here we go is it this one up
the right
fi that's the
one that's the
one that was way more enjoyable than I
thought it would be wow this guy they
[__] this guy needs to be honestly he
would needs to work for the FBI
he how many times is he gone like this
I'm way ahead of you but has only been
watching the Blue Jays you know I'm way
ahead you it was John
Rood I'm way ahead of
you
wow
incredible
um we need to take a break I need to put
my plug my computer in it's going to die
I buy uh like clo I got to plug my
computer in so we cut a little bit sorry
um I buy clothes and [__] and like I I
gotta I gotta stop buying clothes dude I
have too many clothes
and I think it's I don't think it's an
addiction well everything with me is an
addiction so you know God damn I can't
stop playing Royal match on my [__]
phone
now yeah I'm I mean like I'm doing I was
playing Royal match I I
I literally had my phone Calvin was on
my shoulder looking at my phone with me
and uh Calvin says Royal match and I
guess he played before I was like what's
this you want to play I download it you
start playing it and then now I can't
stop playing royal [__] match it's
basically Candy Crush I guess which I
never played Candy Crush but Kristen was
like it's like Candy Crush and I was
like [__] I never wanted to play Candy
Crush anyway I just like I I'll play
this game for like at night while we're
we're trying to watch that [__] dog
[__] movie Rebel Moon and it's it's a
great movie to watch Rebel moon it's a
great movie to [__] do something else
while you're watching it
because I mean Rebel moon was so bad I
turned it off a half with with 20
minutes left you know how bad a movie
has to
be um anyway uh so I'm just like
addicted to this [__] game
now I got to stop and I don't think I'm
not I'm I'm not addicted to buy buying
clothes but I know that when I buy
clothes this is crazy dude I'm a chick
when I buy
clothes I buy them because I want them
and then after I buy them and when I'm
driving home I feel so [__] guilty
and bad about it yes dude he's got deep
issues bro I bought
[Music]
overalls have worn them yet yes bought
them this
[Music]
Summer yes they were at Hefty
price [__] yeah when I bought them I
thought I'm going to wear these without
a shirt like I was the [__] guy in
of my Cen
yes dude like I'm trying to pet bunnies
yes [__] yeah dude I got overalls and I
thought I wouldn't wear a shirt under
him like I was about to kill some
bunnies by mistake in a with a bunch of
hay around
yes [__] yeah I'm
Lenny or whatever the
[__]
um
so I bought the overalls and I felt bad
and I got the overalls in my
[__] closet and every time I pass by
the overall I'm like oh yeah I bought
those in
Vegas dude buying overalls in Vegas is
like the
[__] I mean dude I don't even know
how to like buying overalls in Vegas
that's what I did well that's creepy
tell me more about
that I'm going to wear in one day and
I'm going to [__] absolutely kill it
dude I'm going to get a turtleneck not
only that and then I'm going to I got
toar you know what dude I got that
[__] [__] sick tattoo of the eagle
on my chest dude oh [__] yeah I didn't
even have the tattoo when I got the
overalls now I got the overalls [__]
that dude Elma look sick with that on
man plus my shoulders are beefy I did
shoulders today oh dude hey yeah Chris
Leah doesn't do landmines okay right
yeah uhhuh yeah you that must be AI
because crystalia does at
landmines [__] dum dum
yeah he doesn't do three different
versions of them yeah oh that was AI
then did you check the hands did they
look
weird yeah it wasn't deah where was the
thumb on what side of the right hand
yeah it was it wasn't
deah um so anyway I I got to stop
because I also wear no matter how many
clothes you have unless you're honestly
a a
chick or or Brendan sha you wear the
pretty much the same thing all the time
you
know but I I got these clips on
Instagram and Tik Tok it's like I want
to wear different [__] for the [__]
Clips because I don't want everyone to
think that the [__] Clips come from
the same
show what what a world we live in
dude um so anyway dude I got to stop
buying
clothes or do I my wife made makes me
feel totally okay about it I'm like B
[__] when I tell her I'm playing royal M
I played Royal match too much today she
says honey you're enjoying yourself I'm
like dude who are you John
Lenin what do you mean sweetie you're
enjoying yourself you're passing time if
you're enjoying yourself it's fine yeah
but I but I purchased inapp [__] like
I I I paid money to I did inapp
purchases on this game for what it's
just it's it's absolutely like I've
probably spent $200 on Royal
match dude you
know I straight up that's
so that's so
whack it's fun though they're playing
with loud toys is it okay all right I
got toys I got kids in the background
just like yeah just annoying to me but
luckily I could phase it out dude I'm a
professional
um what is That Yo nothing's creepier
than you're you're sitting at alone
you're sitting alone in your house
watching something you know and I like
to watch Thrillers and horror movies and
sometimes Kristen goes to bed before I
do and I'm just watching the [__]
playing Royal match and all of a sudden
it'll be like oh hello there from my
[__] toy box and I'm like nothing
moved what is it is it [__] and I got
to go find out which one it is and it's
not saying the [__] what I'm looking for
it it's only saying the [__] when I sit
back down and I got [__] chips and
guacamole and I'm eating yeah I keep it
lean but sometimes okay confession I do
eat chips and guacamole and a brownie
sometimes but yeah
man I watched this one thing on on
Netflix called um it was about twins and
it was a series man Netflix will make
[__] anything dude it was a it was a
documentary about first of all I looked
at it said these twins are going to eat
different things for three weeks or two
months or something and uh and and then
we're going to document the change in
their bodies and I'm like oh that's
interesting I go to the thing it's a
[__] series and I'm like what how is
this a
series this should just be 30 minutes it
shouldn't even be 30 minutes hey here's
Dave here's Frank they're gonna eat
[__] different [__] for two months
cut two it's been two months Dave's a
little fatter now but it's a [__]
series like six it's like Eight Episodes
they got a bunch of different twins from
different for walks of life I get that I
understand you know you got you got to
have whites you got to have black
lesbians and then you got to have like
Asians and you got to have old guys and
you got to have young
and you know you got to have different
you have different you got you got to
have gays and lesbians otherwise it's
not going to be a a valid thing even
though sexuality has nothing to do with
what you eat and then um and then I'm
like and I'm like watching this thing
and I'm and and go and I'm as I'm
watching it I'm like they tricked me
dude this is a whole series and I'm
watching it and now all it's basically
doing is one of the twins goes vegan and
one of the twins gets to eat meat so
basically only one twin changes their
[__] lifestyle because the other twin
just eats whatever the [__] they were
going to eat anyway they eat [__]
pizza or burgers or whatever and the
other guy's like I'll be fine with this
lettuce and so I'm on episode two and
I'm like dude this whole thing is like a
cover for like getting people to feel
bad about the meat they eat and so now I
got to feel bad I'm eating like you know
I didn't know farmed salmon can make you
like grow two
dicks apparently farmed salmon is like
one of the worst thing you could eat
because they like they breed where they
[__] they don't clean where they
[__] and it's like then they get all
sores on their bodies and then you're
eating the sores you're eating the [__]
sores from the
and I'm like oh God I got to think about
this when I'm eating salmon when it's
like dude I just want to live in The
Matrix I want to eat the meat and I want
to think the meat tastes great even
though it's just a bunch of ones and
zeros I don't give a [__] there's enough
[__] to worry about I got kids
man right now I got to worry about is
the [__] sustainable is it nice is it
good is it okay is it wild salmon which
by the way wild salmon sounds worse than
farm salmon but it's better cuz it's out
in the wild but you think about eating
wild salmon it sounds like something
like mad cow
disease regular salmon is what I want
where are the Salmons that are just
chilling we all know where they are
they're not that wild and they're just
kind of hanging out in whatever the the
The Creeks version of a living room
[Laughter]
is you know farm raised chicken forget
it eat it you're getting cancer when
someday that's the worst time to get
cancer someday you don't even know when
it's coming if someone could be like yo
you're going to get cancer two 20 uh 56
you be like all right now I know when
I'm going to get it time to [__]
absolutely ball out until then but if
you just know you're going to get it one
day and you are if you're eating Farm
chicken and farm salmon and you are if
you're not eating enough broccoli and
you
are you're getting cancer
someday live with that worry so now
Netflix tricked me I thought I was
watching an inter thing about twins
eating and I'm watching a thing about
how bad meat is in the
US I Hade a chicken sandwich last night
the whole time I was thinking about that
thing I still ate the chicken sandwich
and the chicken sandwich had [__]
bacon on
[Music]
it and Mayo which is made from what has
eggs in it and so that's you know it's
like everything the bun probably had
butter on it which is made from dairy
and then [__] everything everything I
was eating was cancer city
dude
damn it's really hard to not live in
fear
huh all
good anyway uh that's it dude you guys
thank you for listening if you want
that's the end of the YouTube episode if
you want to check out the rest of the uh
episode go to uh patreon.com christalia
and get the uh rest of the episode and
you can also get uh the we do uh an
episode a month that's only on patreon
and there's like 40 of them out there
now so you can go just pay it's six
bucks get to listen and or watch all of
those uh episodes um and so sign up now
we appreciate also it's because of you
guys on patreon that this pod podcast
exists we love you we preach and um also
I'll be in Sacramento and Phoenix and
Brea and uh Colona and a bunch of
different places Corps Christie Houston
Chris lea.com uh Vancouver uh see you
see you on the road soon all right guys
thanks
[Music]
bye